[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to reboot
GameSpot's opinion editorial show I'm
Mike McCarty and I'm Jake Decker
and last week we published an episode
about cuphead and how that sparks a
conversation around the challenges that
developers come into when they're
talking about difficulty in games
cuphead if you don't know for a lot of
people is very difficult but they was
designed you know to be more challenging
platformer running gun shooter it's one
of my favorite games of the year Jake
you've also played a lot of it I love it
I it is it is tough but it's definitely
that that's part of the design right
it's built to trial and error you figure
out like Dark Souls yep not a whole lot
more to say than what you already said
about it yeah I a lot of people I think
saw the title of our video and then I
really went to the comments yeah I think
they were thing saying I was saying that
cuphead has a problem with difficulty
which wasn't my point at all that was
just like the one that gave spark to the
idea of like if you buy a game are you
entitled to see all of it my personal
opinion usually you know that was the
thing I don't I didn't have necessarily
an opinion on this I do think that games
that can figure out ways like shadow of
Mordor or resin before or left for dead
or XCOM - Fire Emblem any games that can
figure out a way to play with difficulty
in a creative way are more impressive to
me than games that are specifically
designed to be you know accessible or
specifically designed to be hard but I
love cuphead for what it is and it's not
any less impressive than the other ones
because it's hard I think it's just very
admirable when developers can find
creative loopholes but when to the
YouTube comments and the GameSpot
comments found ones that were actually
constructive that clearly watched the
video so I'll get right into him the
first one I think was part of a bigger
bait Dave rabbit one on YouTube said the
real problem is that more players
nowadays don't realize that game devs
don't owe you anything
difficulty is a major component of the
developers vision and drastically
warping it just because some people
might not like it is pure nonsense it
would be like being maddening and an
artist for using the color red in a
painting and then protesting to make
them change it to blue this gets even
more important when the game in question
is made by a small independent team
games like cuphead are a product of love
and passion in this case from studio
mvhr they are made following a specific
concept and stay true to it because the
developers care about it and want to
make something exactly the way they
envision they are not making a game for
you they are making it because it's
their dream I think this is one of the
bigger questions it's our
the episode gave rise to two things I
kind of agree with this I do think that
there's two ways of looking at it
there's one way you're looking at games
as expression on the developer's part
not to sound too like pretentious about
it but it is it's people making this
thing that they love studio mvhr there's
a few people but you know the two
principle people are the moldenhauer
brothers who are making it Chad and his
brother and I think they're right if
they take if they made this game less
difficult it wouldn't be coming but I do
think that they still have to have an
audience in mind rather than trying to
appeal to the masses which that's the
one thing I want to clarify I don't
think res Evil 4 appeals to the masses I
don't think left for that appeals to the
masses because they have these dynamic
difficulty kind of sliders I think that
actually just makes it more impressive
that developers can find creative ways
around that problem of how do we get
different players into it but I don't
know like you were saying with cuphead
you find it the difficulty is like
intrinsic to it do you think like that
games all need to be accessible or there
can be games that are made you know for
specific subsets people I lock up head
or Dark Souls or something like that no
I mean I I think I do not think every
game should be accessible to everyone I
am I love the fact that cuphead is
really hard I love the fact that some
people may not be able to see it see the
whole thing I mean I don't love that
like I don't love that some people are
gonna get stuck and frustrated not
finish the game but I definitely think
that that is that was part of their
vision and it makes total sense that
this game is so difficult I myself I've
not finished cuphead I'm on the last
world now and it is very hard and and I
I think the biggest difference is that
if with cuphead with Dark Souls is it's
not really about difficulty as much as
about persistence and I think that isn't
a very important part that is a very
important part of the game like when I
play a boss it's like all right whether
it be Dark Souls or cut pad I'll play it
a couple times Mike okay I think I'm
starting to figure this out try it again
they'll go to the next phase all right
I'll die try it again try it again try
it again try it again in order to get
that satisfaction you have to have that
difficulty and sure you could have a
slider and I think with a triple-a game
they would definitely need a difficulty
slide or a way to make the game easier
which they do
but it's kind of it's not a very good
difficulty slider I guess or not a very
good difficulty option yeah
but I think with a game that small I
think it totally makes sense for it to
be that hard and require that much
persistence because otherwise I think it
would just be a pretty looking game I
don't think there'd be much more to it
yeah they sold a million copies which is
awesome for them yeah a small city from
Toronto I believe and I'm mistaken and
and I'm not surprised it's a fantastic
game it might be in my top 5 of the year
definitely top 10 time will tell a lot
of good games out this year but yet I
find Cup had much harder my people are
comparing it to Dark Souls I think
that's honestly like a trite comparison
I think of that or some just because
they're difficult I am one of those
people not to sound elitist I don't
think Dark Souls games are that hard I
think compared to cup head they have way
more room for error
yeah I think the thing with Dark Souls 2
in particular is that you can definitely
like if you're fighting a boss too tough
what you do is you just grind you know
yeah it's an RPG you level up you grind
you get yourself more prepared you
upgrade your weapons with cuphead it's
like all right like didn't work just
keep going keep going keep going keep
going and III think that's the point you
play leia two hours until you finally
beat the boss actually i don't think a
boss take me two hours yeah but i have
spent a long time on some found that you
do need to develop your skills more in
cuphead than in Dark Souls Dark Souls
with it yeah I mean there's more you
have a whole z-axis to work with that
you can dodge on and a lot of bosses you
know have those little the frames where
they can't hit you and that's key to
that but Dark Souls also has the buddy
system sure yeah and we touched on at
home yeah buddy system like From
Software's games are brilliant I think
the order that I like them in is
blood-borne then Dark Souls and then
Demon Souls Dark Souls 3 and then too
but I think all of them are great
because they have options for people who
want to see all of it and like live in
this world I but you don't want to play
co-op maybe or you know like some and a
friend or you know just an npc or just
start with an easier class rather than
the deprived go with a sorcerer etc but
that's why I brought that up and
Dark Souls in that case was a relevant
comparison so the next one is from muddy
on YouTube aneesa's I'm getting a bit
older now and feeling the arthritis in
my hands and it prevents me from playing
games like cub head as I know I won't be
able to complete them so it can kill
some gamers enjoyment and hurt their
sales having difficulty options just
seems like common sense yeah we touched
on this briefly unfortunately I you know
I don't have a I'm not super well versed
and I know there's like a lot of sites
and charities like AbleGamers devoted to
you know accessibility in games in terms
of literal motor functions and you know
like other obstacles that me and you
don't face every day us for instance and
I touched on it later I said some people
need specially controlled specially made
controllers for their you know they
don't have the same motor skills of
rails or they're a little bit less
dexterous or have less effective motor
skills that's that's awesome the
charities like that exist and it sucks
for people like muddy mentioned like his
arthritis prevents him from playing
something like cup had that you know a
lot people have carpal tunnel syndrome
that can mess with that but then there
are things that are worse right like not
every has the same active nervous system
that allows them to play tough games
like this imagine it must be pretty
frustrating for people like money or
people that you know like right for
AbleGamers to go into a game hoping to
see it all but knowing they physically
cannot no matter how much time or
patience or perseverance they have yeah
but yeah muddy unfortunately Cup it's a
great game but the very least look it up
on YouTube it's not the same at all but
it's worth seeing how like the great
design that went into it yeah I mean you
miss the satisfaction of defeating your
boss but I still think it's totally
worth it just to see the c-d-c the
animation the design the character is
it's fantastic yeah
alright cool and the last comment comes
from our site on GameSpot Richard the
third this is part it was a really long
largely critical comment so we welcome
those so I just want to put the last
part because this touches on something
that we touched on in the episode being
challenged that's about 90 percent of
the reason I play them instead of
watching movies talking about games if I
ever get to where I don't have time for
games anymore I won't sit around and ask
them to change as a whole what [ __ ]
again if you watch the video we talked
about how
not everybody plays games for the same
reason Richard the third plays them to
be challenged I do the same thing most
of the time other people play for
escapism getting into you know the
northern kingdoms in The Witcher 2 just
explore that too some people play them
for the story I usually don't but I love
them they can tell a good story around a
good game play some people play it for
finding their own stories and shadow of
mordor or pray or arc Dishonored people
play games for different reasons people
play destiny to to to catch up with
their friends or their siblings like
myself they haven't they haven't taught
spoken to in a while that's where my
problem becomes like not everybody plays
for the challenge Richard the third
that's great you do I do - like I said
blood burns one of my favorite games not
just to sound like oh I have gamer cred
or whatever because I love blood-borne
but I I play different games for
different reasons and again in the video
we talked about that but I'm not saying
every developer needs to cater to every
kind of person who plays I just think I
would like to see more creative uses of
difficulty ala resonable for shadow of
mordor Dark Souls I kind of agree with
you I think the biggest reason I play
games is for escapism immersion I think
that is something in my opinion that I
can't really get anywhere else
although and I think that's one of the
reasons why I like cuphead is because
the world is so well designed in my
opinion and it's the art design that is
why I keep playing and it's not
necessarily difficult the wall I do love
the feeling of beating a boss and that
honestly can't really be matched
Inessa yeah exactly that can't be
matched in except by another game right
but I mean most of my time I spent
playing RPGs like The Witcher wearing a
[ __ ] shirt of it
divinity shield like I've been playing a
lot of divinity and that game is hard as
well but I don't play it because the
challenge I play it because I want to
play with a friend
yeah and I think the world is great and
I love all the little stories that get
told throughout that whether they be
guided by the developer or they're
guided by it yourself yeah we have a
busy week coming up so the next episode
will be October 29th October 27th is
that amazing / crazy day that is a Super
Mario Odyssey that's discrete origin
design Wolfenstein - the new Colossus so
we have a few ideas we're tossing around
I
I kind of have like an idea for each
game I just need to get my hands on each
of them you should do a three parter
Jesus that'd be crazy Saturday Sunday
Monday episodes uh me and Jake will talk
about more I can't tease specifically
what we're gonna talk about we actually
did go along with what we teased last
episode with cuphead but um we have a
tough decision ahead of us maybe we'll
do a video outside of reboot or
something if we do have something we
really want to say about both games
other than that I'm sure we could still
talk about super mario odyssey after
like the next episode two weeks after
because that game is from everything
that we've seen I'm assuming that game
will be great and still worth talking
about you should find a way to tile
through them together and in one video
I'll try yeah I'm not making any
promises they're all on the Nintendo
switch that's not true Wolfenstein Super
Mario is Wolfenstein this next year but
I haven't agreed is not at all nope but
we'll figure something out either way
there's a lot of source material to work
with but as always thank you for joining
thank you for coming on youtube or
GameSpot check back every Sunday at 11
a.m. Pacific that is 2 p.m. Eastern if
you're in the United States we have an
episode every other Sunday and then we
do these episodes Q&A episodes on the
off week and we always appreciate your
comments concerns criticisms and thank
you so much for being part of the show
and we'll see you next week
[Music]